الزلازل لا يمكن ايقافها اول التنبؤ بها
لكن الساعات الاولى التي تلي الكارثه تلعب
دورا محوريا في احتواء الزلزال ودعونا
نعود لدقائق الاولى التي ثلاث الهزه
ونتتبع خطه الانقاذ التركيه من بدايتها
مباشره بعد الهزه الاولى كلفت اداره
الكوارث والطوارئ افاد بجهود الانقاذ
والاغاثه والتي بدورها جندت
9700 عنصر من اصل خمسه عشر الفا غالبيته
فرق الانقاذ اتجهت نحو مركز الهزه ما صعب
الوصول للمناطق الاخرى مطارات جنوب تركيا
دمرت والطرقات السريعه لم تعد سالكه
المتطوعون وحدهم من تكفل بالضحايا وكنتيجه
تم انقاذ
6645 شخصا فقط في اليوم الاول في اليوم
الثاني تضاعفت اعداد عناصر افاد وبدا
الجيش يتدخل تدريجيا
استخدمت السفن استخدمت السفن العسكريه في
ايصال المساعدات بحرا الى المدن الساحليه
مثل اسكندرون التي اشتعلت النيران في
مبانيها بينما بدات فرق الانقاذ الدوليه
تصل المحافظات الفريق الاسباني الى كهرمان
مرعش الفرنسي الى عثمانيه والامري الى
اليمان الا ان المناطق البعيده التي لا
تطل على البحر باقيه دون نجده لليوم
الثالث انطاكيا
وذلك بعد ان صخرت وزاره الدفاع التركيه كل
امكانيات الجيش المتاحه استخدمت المروحيات
العسكريه لبلوغ المناطق المعزوله لاول مره
فيما اعيد توزيع فرق الانقاذ الدوليه على
المناطق بحسب الحاجه في اليوم الرابع باتت
اعمال الانقاذ اكثر تنظيما خاصه بعد وصول
9400 عنصر انقاذ دولي عناصر الجيش في
الميدان بلغ عددها 25
الا ان اعداد المتطوعين لا تزال تمثل نصف
المنقذين 53 الفا من اصل مئه واربعه الاف
من تم انقاذهم على يد عناصر مدربه يمتلكون
فرص نجاح اكبر من غيرهم